- I'm back with actress
and dog lover, Olivia Munn.
Also joining us now is one
of America's top gearheads.
He's hosted a whole slew of NASCAR shows.
He's also covered the Kentucky Derby,
and the Olympics, as a
correspondent for NBC Sports.
Now he's switching gears, get it,
as host of the new smash hit game show,
"Floor is Lava" on Netflix.
Check it out.
- [Rutledge] With Gerald's
basketball background,
netting that last leap
should be no problem.
(suspenseful music)
(liquid splashes)
Oh no.
Houston, we've got a problem.
- (screams) Ah, it's the lava, no!
(liquid bubbles)
- All right, y'all.
Well, let's bring
Rutledge Wood on in here.
Hey, what's up, Rutledge, how ya doing?
- Hi, guys.
I'm great, how y'all doing?
- Hey, Rutledge.
- I've got Olivia Munn as well.
I was like, I'm gonna keep her in,
'cause we both are into
games, and obviously--
- This is awesome.
- "Floor is Lava" is hit.
So, Rutledge, like your
show is ridiculous,
but it's also insanely popular.
So tell everybody how it works.
- All right, so basically
we have a gigantic room
filled with magic lava.
And you're probably wondering,
where do you get magic lava?
Craigslist, and I got a great deal
on about 80,000 gallons or so.
And we have these insane kind of rooms.
It might be a kitchen, it
might be a planetarium,
and you basically have to get
from one side to the other,
using your team.
And whoever gets there the fastest,
with the most people, wins $10,000.
So, I know you two love games.
I feel like y'all would be naturals at it,
but it's pretty hard.
- I love games.
It is probably pretty hard.
Challenge accepted, Rutledge.
(Rutledge laughs)
So wait, Olivia, did you
want to ask Rutledge anything
about the game, anything?
- I wanna know, how do
you guys come up with
the different obstacles all the time?
'Cause I feel like that's one
of the biggest challenges.
How do you constantly
keep it new and fresh?
Kind of like Ninja Warrior-esque, right?
- Sure, yeah.
Well, I mean, let's be honest.
Let's give credit where credit's due.
Without you, Olivia,
I don't think stuff like this would exist.
I mean, they could've
called it "Floor Olivia,"
but that's really besides the point.
Okay so, that being said,
it was this incredible
gal named Megan McGrath.
She had this great idea that said,
"Let's take this game that
we all played as kids,
"and try to make it
fresh and fun and new."
Because like, Kelly's obviously in like
a world's hyper studio.
But like Olivia, when
I see your living room,
I already think you're
kind of at an advantage.
You've got chairs.
I don't know if that wall
stuff could take my weight,
but it might take yours.
Like, it's just a game that
anyone could play at home.
So, it was trying to make
all these kind of secret things in there
and just make it fun for everybody.
- Yeah.
- Okay, well, Rutledge, Olivia
played this game as a kid.
So, what house games
did you play as a kid?
- Ooh, now keep in mind,
I grew up in Alabama.
So, our games were a little more--
- I love the southern feel today, yes!
Okay, keep going.
- Right?
- Y'all know, our games are like who,
does anyone here own a ball?
You do?
Let's play that game.
(Kelly and Olivia laughing)
We played, my parents had a long hallway,
and we played dodge ball with,
we would take like a bunch of
tube socks and ball them up.
And we would like line
them up in this area.
But, I don't know about y'all.
There were some about being
a kid and being on carpet,
and having things hurled
at you at a high velocity.
I got hurt way more
often playing that game
than I should have, but
that's kinda the fun of it.
- That reminds me of the game
that we'd play all the time,
as children who didn't have money,
which was, get in a blanket,
everybody into the blanket,
like all five kids,
the top of the stairs that are carpeted,
and then just make it down.
- Yes, you slide down, like a sled!
Yes.
- We tried that.
I tried that in the laundry
hamper, and it went pretty good,
but I was just big enough as a kid,
about a fourth stair down,
and I just sort of darted.
- Toppled?
- Yeah.
But that's, you know, you live and learn.
- That's awesome, that's awesome.
Okay, so, Rutledge, I understand the game
has made you pretty popular
with your girls, right?
- Yeah, it's fun.
You know, I've got three daughters.
And y'all know like there are
some projects that you do,
that your friends and family
are like really excited about.
But for my daughter's
Elsie, Millie, and Hattie,
Elsie is 12, Millie is nine, Hattie's six,
they've never had something like this
where they could be that excited.
And I knew it was a big
deal because Elsie, now 12,
beautiful young lady,
she's texting some friends.
And so, this boy that I know
that kinda has a crush on her,
texted her, and the boy was like,
"Hey, is that your dad
"on that Netflix show, "'Floor is Lava?'"
And she was like, "Yeah."
And he said, "Cool, have
you seen all the shows?"
And she reads that text to me, like,
"He asked if I saw the shows, Dad.
"Of course I saw the shows!
"How am I supposed to answer?"
And it was this incredible
moment, 'cause I thought like,
that's my girl, you bet.
Did I see the shows?
It's my dad, of course I saw the show.
So, it's really fun to--
- My kids don't, I mean,
some kids don't watch
their parents' stuff,
they're like over it (laughs).
- Well, and let's be honest,
I've not been the hit
factory, Kelly, that you have.
I'm sure after like, "Ah,
Mom's got another number one."
- My kids are too young, they
don't care what I do (laughs).
- Well one day,
like one day there's
gonna be this real thing
where they're like, "Oh my gosh.
"Yeah, your mom's a hit maker.
"She's like Midas touch, this is amazing."
So for right now, it's pretty cool
for the kids to have that
kind of thing, you know?
- My dogs watch all of my things.
(Kelly laughs)
- Yes, huge fans.
- I am a hit with them.
All right, wait, Olivia,
so you're as competitive as I am, I hear.
I'll bet, you know,
I might know a little bit more
about superheroes than you.
I know you played superhero,
but I was just wondering
if you wanna play a
little game to find out.
'Cause Rutledge kind of
challenged us a minute ago.
I'm just saying.
- I'm really bad,
I have like a horrible
memory with these things.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- [Rutledge] That's perfect!
- I'm actually slightly terrified as well,
'cause while I do love the movies
and I love like growing up with them,
I don't know that I'm going to nail this.
So watch us both epically
fail together (laughs).
Wait, Rutledge, will you
help us out by refereeing?
- Yeah, you know what, I
had a minute just then,
I just wrote a few questions.
(Kelly laughs)
- All right, y'all, I'm
back with Olivia Munn,
and "Floor is Lava" host, Rutledge Wood.
We're going to play a special version
of Rutledge's game show right now.
This is called, what is it called?
Let's show your sign.
Show your sign.
- It's called, "Oh-Lav-ia."
- "Oh-Lav-ia," get it?
(upbeat rock music)
All right, here's how it works.
Rutledge will read each
of us a trivia question,
one at a time.
If we get it right, we get a point.
But, if Olivia or I get it wrong,
we have to take a shot of lava, or a sip.
AKA hot sauce that we have
here at our Zoom desks.
And whoever gets the most points wins.
So, and in honor of Olivia and me,
because I love superheroes too,
all the trivia questions
are superhero theme.
So, here we go.
Are you guys ready?
- (exhales) This feels so official.
Like that was absolute
official game show read.
That was so impressive.
- Rutledge, I'm in it.
Okay.
- [Rutledge] In it to win it.
- This is "Oh-Lav-ia," go.
- Here we go.
- Okay.
- Question one, this one's for Olivia,
which film started off
the current Marvel superhero universe?
- "Iron Man."
(bell dings)
- Oh, that's correct.
She's on the board.
- Hey, Kelly, I'm just
gonna drink my water,
not the hot sauce.
(Kelly laughs)
- Oh, show off, okay.
- Rubbing it in, I love Olivia Munn!
Okay.
- Little bit of a flex there.
Here we go.
Question two, Kelly, what
weapon does Thor carry?
- Oh, a hammer (scoffs).
You know what?
Gonna take a little bit of my milk, Oliva.
- Oh, wow.
- I'm lactose intolerant.
- Me too, mine's almond (laughs).
(Rutledge laughs)
- Mine's oat.
- Yeah, I wanna say, y'all
better get right with oatly,
that stuff's amazing.
Here we go, question three.
Olivia, "Oh-Lav-ia,"
how many actors have played the role
of Peter Parker slash Spiderman,
in the live action films?
- Tobey Maguire, Andrew
Garfield, the new British kid.
He's British, right?
- Is that really important right now?
(both girls laugh)
- You don't know how my mind works.
- Let's just assume
then, yes, he's British.
- And there was, well
those are the first three,
but then there's more after that.
I'm gonna say, live
actions, TV and everything,
it's gotta to be more.
Let's say, it's gonna be
like 10, or 15, or 20,
or 10, or 12.
- You are totally taking
this hot sauce, chick.
(buzzer buzzes)
- Three, drink up.
- [Olivia] It was three?
- [Rutledge] It was three.
Yes, you had it, then
you doubted yourself.
- The thing I didn't know
he was tricking you on,
if that that new one,
the animated one counted.
- Well, I didn't know if he meant back in
like the olden days,
was there another one?
- I would have given you four,
but 15 is just, it's not,
that's not four's neighbor.
- First of all, I love your
vat of hot sauce (laughs).
- By the way, this came
from you, Kelly Clarkson.
I know, okay, well I love
that we sent you the pandemic,
the Costco version of hot sauce.
We wanted you to not run out in the next--
- We got this, we got this.
You guys sent me shot glasses.
- Drink up (laughs).
- Oh, wow, boy, just--
- It comes out really slow.
Is this enough?
- You can literally sip,
'cause I literally have
to sing after this.
I can't shoot this.
- [Rutledge] You're fine.
- [Olivia] Wooo!
- Ooh, there it is, chase it.
Kelly, are you ready?
- I'm ready.
- Here we go.
Question number four,
how did the Fantastic Four
get their super powers?
- I'm gonna say, I mean, I've
seen kind of a poster for it.
So, I'm gonna say from the environment.
Something happened with the environment?
- Okay, okay, yes.
You've got something that's very vague.
Can you roll that ball down
the hill a little more?
- Okay.
That was a good guess, wow.
Something happened with the environment.
There was an explosion.
- Could be, yes.
- Because of something,
and there were scientists
testing stuff and it got out.
And then it hit, them.
And then they were affected.
And then they blew up.
- Let me check with the judges.
Olivia, do you buy most of that?
- I mean--
- I'm gonna say I have to sip this.
- For never having seen them,
I think that she did a pretty good job,
and I would give it to her.
I believe that they crashed back to earth.
- Cosmic or space radiation.
So really, you were there.
- Oh, I didn't get it.
(buzzer buzzes)
- It was close, okay, all right.
(Olivia claps)
I felt like you did.
You basically, like there was a thing
and then there was a problem with it.
(Kelly screams)
- That's integrity, Kelly.
That's what you're feeling right now.
I appreciate it.
- Oh my god, it's so spicy!
- You need a pickle back.
I'm gonna start a Nickelback
cover band with pickles
called "Pickleback."
- That means a lot.
- Oh my god, this is so hot!
- All right, Olivia, we only
got time for a couple more.
Here we go.
Which superhero does Bruce
Banner transform into?
- I know this one.
- Course you do 'cause
you missed the last one.
You gotta know this one.
No pressure, no pressure.
He was a just assume he
was a tax accountant,
and then sometimes he got different.
- [Kelly] Really, just different.
- Turnt, as the kids say.
- I don't know why Bruce Loren is--
- Bruce Banner.
Did you see--
- - Oh yeah, I know, it's Hulk.
(bell dings)
- [Kelly] Yes!
- There we go.
- Because, I don't know why, but hey.
- I know, I took some milk for you
'cause my mouth is still on fire (laughs).
- All right, Kelly, we're
gonna give you one last one.
Oh, I'm gonna pick.
what would Groot say if he
wanted to tell you he was hungry?
- "Groot."
(bell dings)
Exactly!
He would just say, "Groot,"
'cause that's all he says.
That's his one word.
- He'd say, "I am Groot."
- That's a good question (claps).
- I love "Guardians of
the Galaxy," I love them.
Anyway, that was awesome.
Olivia, well done.
My mouth is on fire still.
So you win.
You guys are so awesome.
Thank you so much for playing.